comment remettre l'europe au coeur des
médias français question vieux serpent
de mer ou nécessités actuelles j'ai
envie de dire nécessités actuelles à la
proche de la présidence française de
l'union européenne et a un grand besoin
d'informer autour des sujets européens
61% des français utilisent encore les
médias traditionnels audiovisuel radio
et télévision comme moyen préféré pour
s'informer alors c'est une exigence
démocratique à laquelle nous devons
répondre triple responsabilité
les institutions européennes des ventes
devenir plus politiques plus
transparents nous les politiques
français nous devons informer aussi bien
plus et mettre en scène et les
rédacteurs en chef devront prendre leurs
responsabilités également pour fournir
ce qui on a besoin au niveau
démocratique
européenne quelques pistes
d'amélioration renforcer le cadre légal
de traitement des questions européennes
dans les médias audiovisuels rendre
beaucoup plus visible aussi le
traitement des questions européennes
ici chez nous à l'assemblée nationale et
créer un véritable statut de
journalistes européens en mettant les
moyens adéquate en face